[Music]
welcome to Baywatch our team is the
elite of the elite for the heart soul of
this very Beach come on Pete make my
patches a little bigger and don't cover
up my front bump you got it huge dick
big dick we're staring into the abyss
here it's up to us restore the Baywatch
brand at One Direction here for the
qualifiers I'm Matt Brodie I don't have
to try out I've got two gold medals hey
Brody yeah we still don't get training
begins at oh six hundred there's nothing
you TV people either refrigerator this
is very watch [ __ ]
what is that you think we do here
prevent people from getting sunburned
occasionally stop them from drowning
nothing I can't save you if you're being
a dick this is the guy you think it's a
good PR opportunity for us look I get it
you're being sasquatch
I'm fast oh [ __ ] then touch him
you suck drugs murder dead body on our
Beach and it all started once she took
over some people are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
that's best the truth is one of you will
probably die yeah what no the only one
that thinks this is clearly a job for
the police
Thank You blue-eyed demon you got one
job make sure swim happy white people
don't drown so why does she always look
like she's running in slo-mo she's the
reason I believe in God
we got to go undercover
yeah wonder cover yeah little to
undercover
the word
Jason Bourne ain't got [ __ ] on me
why are we in the morgue you got to get
some hard evidence what's coming what do
we do now now we hide weird I playing
wanted a doll drawers are empty why'd
you pick that drawer top industry it's
just a little dead man's fat necrotic
liquid fat man will you stop being a
baby mm-hmm
that's it I'm out
[Music]
you